IT'S TIME FOR X IS THE NEW Y.
X IS THE NEW Y.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> HARDWICK: INTERNET TRENDS
COME AND GO FASTER THAN YOU CAN
SAY, "MAN BUN, DAD BOD, ON
FLEEK, NENE."
A POPULAR GENRE OF TREND PIECE
MAKING THE ROUNDS RIGHT NOW IS
THE ONE LETTING US KNOW THAT
BLANK IS THE NEW BLANK.
FOR INSTANCE, ARE SLOTHS THE NEW
CATS?
UM, NO, THEY'RE NOT, BY THE WAY.
THEY'RE... THEY'RE NOT, AT ALL.
NONE OF THIS IS STUPID AT ALL.
COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
COME UP WITH AS MANY X IS THE
NEW Y ARTICLES AS YOU CAN IN 60
SECONDS, AND BEGIN.
JIM JEFFERIES.
>> IS ORANGE THE NEW TRUMP?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
MARY LYNN.
>> EATING WHILE MASTURBATING IS
THE NEW CRYING WHILE
MASTURBATING.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, DAVID
KOECHNER.
>> IS JENNY MCCARTHY THE NEW
TYPHOID MARY?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
DAVID.
>> FARMERS.COM IS THE NEW
[BLEEP]ING SHEEP.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
MARY LYNN.
>> "UH-HUH" IS THE NEW "OH,
YEAH."
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
JIM JEFFERIES.
>> FISTING IS THE NEW HANDSHAKE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> OH!
>> HARDWICK: NO, GUYS, YOU DID
IT THE OLD WAY-- DO IT THE NEW
WAY.
>> UH...
>> WAIT, UH...
>> HANG... HANG ON.
LET ME JUST...
>> I'LL NEED THE EMMY.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, 100
POINTS TO EACH OF YOU FOR THAT
DELIGHTFUL ACT-OUT.
UH, MARY LYNN.
>> REGRET IS THE NEW NORMAL.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
PERFECT.
KOECHNER.
>> NEW MEXICO IS THE NEW MEXICO.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
>> THAT ONE'S CLEVER.
VERY CLEVER.
>> HARDWICK: MARY LYNN.
>> "HULU AND RELAX" IS THE NEW
"NETFLIX AND CHILL."
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.